hello we're gonna get started here
tonight
my name is Seth manikin I'm the director
of the communications forum and a couple
of quick announcements before we start
first communication forums are held
three times a semester six times a year
if you would like to be informed of
future events there is a sign-up sheet
over there put your name and email and
we will promise that we will only send
you news about our six events a year we
have pretty good ones we had Sarah
Vowell earlier this year John Hodgman
last semester these three we have some
great stuff planned for next semester
already also tonight's forum is being
filmed by c-span so during the question
part of the of the forum if you would go
up to one of the microphones and also
hopefully state your name and your
question
another reason we ask you to say your
name is because we then do a write-up of
all of the forums afterwards which you
will be able to read a couple of days
after the event on our website which is
conformed mit.edu and the last
announcement is that this event tonight
is co-sponsored by radius which is
another group here at MIT I am thrilled
to be able to introduce these three it
is a different three than we initially
thought would be here because Jeff how
is he called me up at a little past five
because his daughter was puking and as
the father of two young kids myself I
said please stay home and so fortunately
Chris couch who writes a lot about
technology works with the Kahn forum is
a brilliant journalist in her own right
has agreed to fill in as a moderator but
let me do introduce everyone Noam Cohen
is the author of the new book that
know-it-alls and that
we'll also be a hashtag tonight and I
think moving forward is that right
know-it-alls gotta get on that yep
Noam and I worked together a decade and
a half ago I've known him ever since he
is a great guy and a brilliant
journalist he covered the influence of
the internet on the larger culture for
the New York Times where he wrote the
link by link column beginning in 2007
his first book that know-it-all is the
rise of Silicon Valley is a political
powerhouse and social wrecking ball is
an intellectual history of Silicon
Valley and critically examines how its
disruptive culture and ideology
belittles civility empathy and even
democracy it was published in October
2017 and it is available for purchase
right here and in addition to to
supporting open discussion we also
support both bookstores and authors so
please by all means buy the book it's a
great book Chris and I both read it and
loved it - nomes
left is Sarah Anne Watson Sarah is a
technology critic who writes and speaks
about emerging issues in the
intersection of Technology culture and
society her work has appeared in The
Atlantic Wired
The Washington Post slate and
motherboard she's an affiliate with the
burcham Klein Center for Internet and
Society at Harvard University and author
of the tau tau R tau tau Center for
Digital journalism's report on the
current state of technology coverage and
then to nomes right to my left now is
Chris couch Chris couch is a science
journalist who I have had the absolute
pleasure of working with for several
years now
she's also the coordinator for the
communications forum her own work
explores the intersections of Technology
in psychology and her by Lyons have
appeared in Nova next MIT Technology
Review Fast Company coexists Science
Friday and Wired magazine we have also
for your convenience put all of their
Twitter handles on the board at
Cohen at SWAT SM what and at couch CS
and without further ado I will turn it
over to Chris sorry about that in
addition to genomes book we have a book
that Jeff co-wrote with Joe Ito the head
of the MIT Media Lab on sale here called
whiplash which is also a great book so
both of those are available immediately
afterwards and Noah obviously will be
here to sign so now without further ado
thank you thank you guys all for being
here we're so excited about this panel I
feel like it addresses a lot of really
important issues I too would encourage
you buy a book it's a great book so
first of all I want to kick off this
panel by talking about a the central
argument of the book and correct me if
correct me if I'm wrong here is really
the the disruption and individualism
that's very endemic to Silicon Valley
has kind of in a lot of ways and eroded
humanity is that fair to say
mm-hmm I mean I was thinking about you
the question like the premise of this
get-together like have they lost our
humanity of course the glib answers did
they have it then the deeper question is
everyone every person has humanity so
what are we really talking about that's
happened and I think it I kind of
approach some of this from the computer
science aspect the book goes a lot of
the history of computer science and
thinking of people's machines and
machines as people is one of the crucial
you know mistakes or paths over on that
I think is is scary so I think that is
kind of denying the humanity of your
fellow people when you think of them
so individualistically as little data
points and i think about like you know
in the introduction we talked about it's
kind of a well-known anecdote about you
know Google's
first design director who you know was
asked to create a design for Gmail and
they were doing it and he like he
suggested a color and you know he and
they instead of using the color he
wanted that right they went and tested
it you know they a be tested 41
different shades of blue and which one
the one that people you
the most was one they were gonna choose
and he eventually resigned over these
kind of issues saying to be a design
director at least then at Google wasn't
like an oxymoron to have a human vision
for what they were doing when they were
gonna test it and they don't apologize
for that because basically they say
though the color the shade of blue we
pick is the most popular one it's led to
200 million dollars in additional
revenue and so I think it's it's it's
that in fact that breakdown I've seen
people as data points and and I think
they're not apologetic about it I think
it leads to bad outcomes did that make
sense can you speak a little bit to what
those outcomes are I mean for people
that are not familiar with with you know
the intricacies of Silicon Valley can
you tell me a little bit about how does
that play out well I guess what I was
trying to argue is that they are taking
this fringe philosophy or ideology
called libertarianism and making it seem
very normal and mainstream and so what
do I mean by libertarianism I mean you
know resisting regulation the idea that
we should regulate taxis or or hotels or
you know you can think of all the
different companies that we should
regulate what children see on video of
not TV that we should regulate who can
pay for political ads I think should
they live in America should they just
declare what they are what they're doing
so that's that's one part of that
ideology that the this this distaste for
regulation and and distrust of
government which i think is really
poisonous tor society so that's one part
I think the extreme idea of free speech
is another one I know all these issues
are complicated we'll talk about whether
I'm coming out too strong I mean to me I
wrote a piece that was in The New Yorker
calm this week about an issue with
Stanford and the bulletin board of
Stanford and whether you should even
back in the 80s whether they should be
any limits on free speech there was a
joke group that told really very little
racist and sexist jokes and Stanford
tried to limit that and there was a such
a fierce pushback from a computer
science department that kind of people
were talking about her now or running
Silicon Valley that it was it was
reversed and like to me you should
having limits on free speech is vital to
having a community that is cohesive and
so that's another dangerous aspect of
that libertarian ideology I think
they're doing all this in you
I think some of it is done in good faith
but I think it's just having horrible
consequences so I wrote this book before
the 2016 election I was certainly
working on it thinking about it but I
think a lot of what happened there a
fruition from that election bears out
these points because you know the fact
that these big companies like Google
Facebook and Twitter are so blase about
the idea that a foreign company in a
foreign country could try to influence
our election or that there should be
disclosure of who's advertising whether
these powerful tools of targeting people
should be used by anybody to stir up
anger and resentment to me shows that
this this disconnect they're not they're
not seeing themselves as custodians of
this powers they have but instead of
exploiting it for profit or for maybe
their kind of utopian visions of I think
like for Mark Zuckerberg isn't a dream
of connecting the world that he thinks
supersedes a lot of other concerns so
that's those are certainly the effects I
would just add one thing as people will
ask me when I've been talking about the
book you know what property to do it
because clearly it wasn't the 2016
election and I kind of think about how
one thing i'ma serve a turning point and
you can look at me as a hypocrite
because it's about using Gmail and I
remember just thinking that the idea
that Gmail would have a computer read
your email which least at least that
used to do in the past and in order to
place ads for it I'm you know my mom
actually you know passed away from
cancer during that time I remember
thinking how I never mentioned the word
cancer in an in an email because I just
didn't want like hey if you thought of
radiation treatments or we know ice
didn't want that and that notion that
like some would be a custodian of my
information they're giving me for free
and would still feel like they had a
right to sort of try to commercialize it
was I think that kind of crystallizing
moment for me to if I think back on it
so so a lot of Sara's work deals with
technology criticism not just of
Technology itself but also of the
culture surrounding it I'm wondering if
from your perspective you know do you
agree with the premise or how do you
feel about the premise I guess of the
culture of the technology world having
an impact on humanity and empathy and
civility agree with with gnomes kind of
overall premise and I think a lot of
people have started to unpack the kind
of implications of the way that
technology is built but also the kind of
assumptions and ideologies that are
acted out and in the technology itself
and obviously looking at the individuals
who are leading these companies and
coming up with these designs and looking
at their assumptions and their
ideologies really do matter I think the
biggest thing for me is you know I like
to think about this in terms of
optimization I think most silicon
Silicon Valley leaders and companies are
designed around questions of
optimization whether it's the design
itself whether it's you know getting you
the information as fast as you can or
connecting people as efficiently as
possible or you know connecting you to
all of the world's material goods for
Amazon those are kind of questions of
efficiency and optimizing for profit
right those are kind of taken for
granted as the right terms of
optimization and I think trying to
unpack what those assumptions are is
really productive starting point to say
okay well what if spending more time on
Facebook wasn't the optimization model
what if it was a quality experience on
facebook what would that look like
how would that change the experience how
would that change the design of the
platform but also you know what would
that change about what Facebook's role
in our lives
is so that's kind of the crux for a lot
of the questions that I continue to ask
about technology and society I think
that the trick is you know using the
terminology of the industry optimization
and the way that they're thinking about
problems and problem solving is actually
a productive way of like sharing
language and trying to get at you know
we haven't necessarily agreed to the
terms of optimization but they're coming
from it at a market perspective and
that's the kind of natural way for
things to evolve but we as a society we
can start to question whether those
those are the terms that we've agreed to
or not one of the things that I thought
was really well done in the book the
book addresses how
many of the issues that we associate
with Silicon Valley now and with the
larger technology world issues privacy
issues of commercialization issues of
users being assessed in ways that they
may not agree to the at least some of
the companies that are major giants
currently Google being the one that
sticks out of my mind really started
with an ethos that was entirely against
all of those things can you speak a
little bit to I mean how did we get here
sure I want to just pick up like that
the I think the way Sarah put all that
was really spot-on and I was reading her
report that she wrote and I think it's
she you know kind of classifies critics
and and I could see myself in it I and I
think that what she's talking about is
like oh very practical ways of trying to
like get to a better place and I think
in this book I was sort of looking at
the history like like you're asking I'm
also trying to ask bigger picture kind
of questions like I think about the
efficiency argument it's not in the book
but I was thinking I was almost gonna
make it the kind of beginning of the
book is this idea of like Gleaners and
the idea then the Bible there's this
kind of instruction that when you have a
feel that you should just give it one go
one pass in harvesting it you shouldn't
go back a second time and efficiently
get every little fruit and kernel you
miss because partly there's an ecosystem
of people who are traveling or poor
people who live off of the the gleaning
and that you know that is an a metaphor
where again you're saying you know what
the efficient thing would be like I have
a farm I need to get all the content out
of it that's what I do I'm a farmer or
you could say well you're part of a
society and actually the efficient thing
is let some kind of scraps be there for
other people because they efficiently
use it you know again it's like using
their language of thinking about the
picture they're you know the the world
they're trying to create and when I an
editor sent me recently a tweet where
someone pointed out that Mark Zuckerberg
was saying how he cared so much about
this election meddling the Russian
meddling the election that he was gonna
the company was gonna spend all this
money to hire people that's why he
mentioned in an investment call because
was so important they were prepared to
lose money over it and of course the
natural comment this person made was
like well you're basically saying you
make money from the current bad
situation that's how important is you're
gonna flip on that one and so that
that's again these efficiencies in the
way they're set up that are really
troubling about what you're asking about
history I was trying to look back I
didn't really know these answers I was
learning about how did we get here that
was definitely question I was trying to
ask and in the end you'll see like kind
of a thesis of the book is that the
computer science half has accounts for
some the hacker kind of mentality
accounts for some of these extreme
ideological ideas about free speech and
kind of lack of diversity and hostility
to outsiders and then you know I kind of
credit or blame Stanford for a lot of
the the kind of profit-seeking and so
you know for me the Stanford the Google
case was a real like just very
enlightening is you go back and read the
original papers that Sergey Brin and
Larry Page wrote when they were
developing this which was really an
incredible invention like the Google
search engine or PageRank you know I
think everyone agrees that they really
didn't maybe they were standing on the
shoulders of others but they really
created something that took this chaotic
thing called the early web and made it
you know coherent and it was incredible
and it's the reason why it like became
so popular it's an amazing invention but
they really also explained as they were
describing this amazing invention why it
needed to be advertising free and needed
to be in the in the actual academic
world that it needed to be a place where
was transparent there shouldn't be these
black boxes now of course it's we just
come to accept the idea that the Google
algorithm and the Facebook algorithm are
these secret things that no one should
know what they're doing and I'm sure
sorry I talked about this and they're
constantly tinkering with it in this
mysterious way I mean they were arguing
that's very bad for science it's very
bad for trusting the system because if
you don't have any you know scrutiny of
it and and so they wrote this paper
explaining all that and at least the way
I see the the story going is that
basically they they are serious
academics their parents were academics
they were getting PhDs off of this
incredible idea they had and then
basically it ended up using so much
bandwidth at Stanford that they were
told you have to start figuring out how
to pay for this not to me it's a fair
question to say couldn't Stanford have
said this is a great invention we're
gonna pay for it of course we're gonna
pay for we pay for like a nuclear
reactor in our in our building you know
it's very important for our studying of
our society and science to do this but
instead they were told you better figure
out a way to do this and they
immediately were connected through the
Stanford network with an investor like
immediately before so early that they
actually didn't they weren't
incorporated so the story that's told in
these books
about how a person who had been a
Stanford Graduate wrote them a check for
Google Inc and they're like there is no
Google Inc he's like there will be take
the check you'll need it soon and like a
month later there was a Google Inc and
they deposit that hundred thousand
dollar check and the rest is history so
I do feel like there was like a maybe
it's a little corny or something there's
like a corruption or you know a kiss he
call it selling out whatever there's a
corruption narrative for them and for
Facebook as well where they really had
some idealism they kind of were in awe
of the power of computers and they
weren't necessarily trying to become you
know billionaires that wasn't what there
was making them tick I think in the book
you'll see there are other characters
like Peter Thiel and Jeff Bezos who were
bankers and that was really what they
were trying to do was to figure out a
way to make money from the unit but
these these idealistic hackers I feel
were kind of led astray a bit that's my
view anyway Sarah even extensively about
how coverage of the technology world has
changed over time can you own a little
bit about you know how has that how is
the media evolved as the tech world has
evolved sure so in the research report I
did for the Tao Center for digital
journalism at Columbia I think one of
the things I was trying to look at was
you know coverage from that kind of
early almost breathless excitement about
the Silicon Valley moment the dot-com
boom and all of that kind of energy that
went into covering before you know the
Amazon era and then later in the Google
and Facebook and and others era and that
kind of starting from a very
business-oriented coverage model or from
a kind of tech bloggers model and so
that kind of breathless coverage moving
into something a little bit more
concerned with you know as the
technology starts to intersect with a
lot of things like politics and people
and society those kind of shifting the
the narrative about what matters about
technology and why this is changing our
lives and affecting our lives and I
think that that shift kind of happens at
a couple different points I think you
2007 or so the iPhone comes out and like
we all of a sudden have dramatically
changed our like day to day relationship
with a computer in our pocket basically
so I think but yet that was still kind
of in that gadget excitement phase and
then we have like a 2013 ish momment
which is the Snowden moment and I think
that's kind of where everyone comes to
terms with the fact that like technology
has both good and bad uses right that to
me is this like larger discourse moment
where everyone excuse me specifically
journalists and publications are willing
to acknowledge that like yeah we need to
think about this also and hold power to
account and and so on I think what's
really interesting right now and I think
I wanted to touch on this a little bit
because right now there you know at this
very moment your book came out there's
Franklin Thor's book the
world-without-end which is a little bit
more about these companies controlling
our access to knowledge and information
there's also the four by Scott Galloway
which is a lot more about the kind of
monopolistic approach of these companies
so a little bit more on the market side
of things but you know you also have Tim
Wu writing about the attention merchants
talking about you know these companies
monopoly over our information and our
attention so I think it's an interesting
moment right now in part because like
all of these books were being written
before the crisis hit so it's it's
fascinating like the writing has been on
the wall for a long time
publishers seem to have acknowledged
this to think that there was like a
market for these books I like to think
of a lot of this and it kind of meta
like where's the audience who does this
who is a spore 2013 was a sort of
important moment I think about I wrote a
piece earlier than that about this
German politician young guy who who
petitioned to get all his data about all
the tracking that was done with with him
and it was like you know and it ran on
link in the front page at the time so I
mean it was it was but it was again you
kind of point out in your in that paper
he wrote that the breakthrough is hard
so like it's writing an article saying
isn't that weird they are keeping all
that data about you but until something
like Snowden really you know gets
attention for a lot of different reasons
it probably takes a while for people to
to see it so I think that probably was a
big change yeah we were talking a little
bit earlier about the problem of access
right like who for a journalist and I
would be curious to hear your take on
this is you know for a journalist to
have access to these companies they have
to kind of stay on their good side to to
a degree and that is especially true if
you're like the business tech journalist
covering the story so you know as more
kind of journalists from different beats
and different walks of life are you know
also coming to terms with technology's
impact on society the narrative starts
to change right I mean because where
you're pointing out is also that one
maybe the benefits from leaving that
kind of gadget phase is that that's less
important so I think there was a sense
that in in 2007 like getting access to
the first gadget is usually important
but now we are you know we're kind of
beyond the gadget phase now the
ramifications become as important in a
well-told story explaining that is very
vital I think there you know I didn't
seek out a lot of access I knew that
there wouldn't you know wasn't really
what they were talking about and I don't
know that a lot of them of such such
there's an incredible site called the
Zuckerberg files where a professor at
the University of wisconsin-milwaukee
has just he kind of over privacy issues
saying that you know they know so much
about us has systematically found
everything that it's like marks like
works ever said and he has they if the
actor like kind of log in with him but
it has access to a usually it's
videotape of it you know a streaming of
it and also text of it everything he's
ever said since he's 19 and you know I
read like a lot of it I mean I think
almost all of it and and so likewise you
know a Marc Andreessen until he deleted
all this tweets he tweeted a hundred
thousand times so it's like you know
there was more than enough about him and
you know Peter Thiel's written two books
I mean one book he talks about a lot
more than the other one but there was an
early book he wrote that was really I
thought really revealing about what his
worldview and you know so they all had a
lot of documentation so I felt like it
wasn't so vital to have an interview
with that when I did try the interviews
it was often very
like meant to be very steamy graphic you
know I'm not not that not that revealing
so yeah I think that there is a
appreciation for the deeper journalism
the more critical journalism you're
talking about I think that's it's great
I think it's what we needed but it has
to be supported by you know the the
institution's the publications to be
willing to stick their neck out and you
know put that forward okay I think
specifically of the kind of Amazon
workplace environment example like you
know the reaction of from Bezos would
for that piece was just like what are
you talking about resign just to fill
everybody in the New York Times ran a
pretty large piece on the inner workings
of Amazon employees and it really
spanned from very low level all the way
up to high ish lovely yeah middle middle
management not all the way to the top
but they really detailed the sort of
breakneck work conditions of that place
and it ended up getting lots and lots of
attention yeah and I felt like the
response that that Bezos gave was a
really a classic libertarian response
and like baseless obviously is the owner
of the Washington Post he's considered
someone call him a liberal carry and I
mean I think he embodies a lot of what
I'm saying in the book and his response
was very clear that he said it can't be
true because these are people who could
go to another company and if they
weren't if they weren't being treated
right thing what just wouldn't work here
so therefore they are being treated
right and because they do work here it's
kind of the same logical here a lot in
Silicon Valley that says there can't be
you know gender you know sexual
discrimination because there would be
these arbitrage opportunities there
would be a company would take all the
great women programmers and they would
be the best company and therefore it
can't exist the market would correct for
it so it's that kind of and that is
another theme of the book it's
definitely this this this detachment
from reality the kind of what was when
you asked about their intentions or
there's something very seductive about
the idea the internet kind of can erase
all the past so we don't deal with the
history even like current racism and
sexism it's a new world and so the to me
was a really interesting anecdote I
don't know if it's in the book but it
was about github and how this company
get cut github had a huge they're really
proud of this this carpet they had there
was a big symbol of github and it had
meritocracy
and they were like we're so proud we
were we wrote a meritocracy and then
women we're walking and saying this is
really offensive that's like what's
offensive meritocracy it's to create the
best rule I mean the best rise up I mean
and they didn't understand that by
writing about having that as they're
like slogan they were in essence saying
what we have now is fair and if you
aren't represented here that's because
you didn't you didn't make it even cut
it so that I did that and I think the
head of github eventually took the
carpet away but was like such a
re-education for him because they really
believe the world has been remade
because it's a vertical world that none
of the legacy problems that are
obviously current don't matter so it's a
real yeah I wanted dole on that baseless
response because it so clearly
articulates this like complete disregard
for the physical world like they're in
Seattle like for them to get another
Silicon Valley job they would actually
have to uproot their families and lives
and everything else it's not just so
it's not as you know fungible making it
out to be
so yeah I mean it's the question is
whether it's on purpose or not like if
he's a smart person and he's saying that
is he really not understand it or is he
sort of you know that was always I
always got hung up on talked about
things like biases and technology both
in terms of biases within the culture of
Technology under representation of a
number of groups of people as well as
biases that are exhibited by the
products themselves whether that's
computer vision systems that have a
harder time detecting certain types skin
or there was an article fairly recently
on women having a hard time getting
prosthetics that fit because they're
largely designed by men I mean so many
of these problems just stem from you
have like a dominant group in power that
you have you have it you know Silicon
Valley is so very much dominated by by
white men first of all from your
perspectives do you see those types of
issues changing changing over time or
right now now we're talking about it
right I mean there are these there
our books are coming out there is a lot
more media coverage on these types of
things I mean is that landscape
beginning to shift or do stills do you
still see it as we have a really long
way to go oh I mean I would say that
that it would require a fort to change I
mean it would require the book is is
fundamentally saying that these these
companies are anti-democratic that they
are against democracy there again how do
we correct in a society for to have
wheelchair access and fill in every
blank ideally we have a democracy where
people all you know it's not true but we
ideally everyone gets to express their
opinion and and that is how you
represent people and and I was struck
like Amy Clovis sure there was a hearing
that the Senate had about that where
they had the the top lawyers the General
Counsel's for Google Facebook and
Twitter there and she was sort of
explaining for them like very patiently
like we live in a representative
democracy so we really it's really
important that we control our elections
you understand that like that's how we
do it and and and so I felt like that is
like a real like message they don't have
that is fun I'm like how do you assure
fairness or you know we have a democracy
we vote we people who are I remember
hearing it said that like that like the
Japanese internment who maybe if there'd
been a japanese-american representative
you know the internment in America of
japanese-americans wouldn't it happen it
you need to have some political way of
correcting these thing so I do think
fundamentally as long as they're gonna
argue that they can self-regulate and
that they are above the government it
won't change so I think the I'm like
kind of optimistic that there could be
some sort of a wave election that will
kind of present a new new path but I
don't think it can be done by themselves
I think it's it's the idea of self
regulation is is it won't work I don't
think they like sixty percent of the
people that care for you is is just
people who are talking about well this
is another problem that stems from pure
self regulation within the technology
world I mean the number of issues that
are endemic to that are just just
astronomical do you think it's fairly
it's hard for anyone to regulate
themselves I mean think about you know I
mean I if I were given free will to like
you know being charged everything I'm
sure I wouldn't be quite as fair you
need checks I mean that's like I mean
I do fundamentally believe in democracy
I think it's a little scary that you get
the sense like in Peter Thiel is a major
you know he I feel like one point in
this book would say that Peter Thiel is
not an outlier that it's that he is
often described as a sort of fringe
character but that maleeh expressing the
the the main thought there which is that
you know the democracy is bad that like
when democracy happens and you have not
smart people running the world and
that's not good and I think they really
but I really believe that I remember
like there was a person Max Levchin who
was who was the co-founder of PayPal
with Peter Thiel I mean he was sort of
saying he believes in regulation but he
doesn't like politicians and like you
know so it's like they kind of they just
think it's not efficient or I don't know
so I mean that's what I do think it gets
down to our democracy though and it is
really important that's why I wrote the
book I mean sir you've written about how
it's specifically within technology
criticisms that that world is also in
certain ways very reflective of
technology and that female voices voices
of minority writers have been overlooked
in an in a systemic way can you talk a
little bit about you know do you see
that end of it changing at all I
absolutely do see that changing which is
part of why I was looking at this kind
of larger ecosystem of people who are
writing about these things
I think certainly in the last couple of
years that it has drastically changed
which is all for the better I think that
also has put pressure on Silicon Valley
to change so at the very least
so speaking of like how now versus in
the future I think we've at least seen
the kind of oh yes we will work on
diversity for hiring we'll work on you
know thinking more about users interests
and needs whether or not that's actually
being effective is another question on
the kind of writing side of it I think
you know I I was really interested in
looking not just at a set of people who
are like covering technology but the
rest of the people who are also
contributing to a larger discourse about
the role of Technology and society and
so some of that has to do with looking
at a whole range of writers not just
technology journalists whose like
it's technology but it's the people who
think of themselves as critics people
who are you know just writing an op-ed
because they their academic work has a
direct response to you know the current
issue on Russia for example so my
interest was in to in trying to
articulate this larger ecosystem of
people who are contributing and a lot of
that has to do with you know women
writing blog posts about you know
terrible things either happening at
their workplace or critiquing a
technology that doesn't include you know
fitness tracking in the iPhone not
having a menstruation tracker you know
those kinds of pieces are coming from a
lot of different directions from a lot
of different disciplinary backgrounds
and existing in a lot of different
places and so obviously that's not
limited to publications but I think
what's what is frustrating is that a
majority of the kind of traditional ways
and places that you would look for
technology coverage for a long time
still were dominated by you know your
standard tech white dude bro sorry no I
like just hearing the list of things
you're mentioning and even the thing I'm
talk about github that was a woman who
was blogging that in fact she had a bad
encounter with Marc Andreessen over and
that's what why I kind of stumble on it
sorry and yeah there are things that no
matter how enlightened you are that it's
not you're not gonna be able to do that
we were I wonder if you like look at the
example of all the coverage of the
harassment and the media particularly
and look at a lot of that are women
journalists who are writing that and I
mean is that like a reason for hope
imagine if there was similar kind of
kind of pushed going on about that with
the way the way Silicon Valley works
written by women journalists who yeah I
mean I'm certainly like especially in
this current like in the last two you
know two months moment I am hopeful I
think when you look back at like what
Ellen Powell went through with her I
think it was kleiner perkins and waning
yeah so Ellen Pao had a I guess she was
in a VC company kleiner perkins right
and
had a sexual harassment issue and that
kind of just got shoved under the rug
basically but that again was you know
probably two years ago at this point she
now has a book out that is all about her
you know follow through on what to do
about this kind of systemic sexism and
not having an ability to have support
and have people take her seriously take
her claim seriously so whatever you
thought of that I'm not gonna remember
the guys name exactly the Google
engineer yeah a lot of people look at me
and go like look up Google did they they
fired this guy you know uh yeah James
two more and like so you're sitting
there saying that there there are
libertarians when in fact they fired
this libertarian guy for his you know
for really uh for his like insidious
ideas and what he put there and I wonder
how do you how do you see that like
because somebody's it was like a PR yeah
James do more
don't know is the author of the infamous
ten page Google memo
it included a pretty large critique of
Google's internal culture and included
some information stating that women
might be naturally inclined to be like
logically biologically less inclined to
for coding yeah than men so whenever
super well and and he ended up getting
fired and then he went on a fairly large
PR push after that saying that you know
it was his like autism spectrum that
like led him to believe this speech but
yes here's the why why is any idea I
remember seeing some on Twitter saying
you know Charles Darwin couldn't work at
Google and I'm sitting there thinking
like you know there's so the problem is
that like Google is now a company that
isn't just doing programming that would
be bad enough the computer lab being so
non-diverse is bad but this is actually
affecting our society so really you you
even Charles Darwin couldn't do other I
mean there are there are so many roles
to be played at Google it's just it's
it's just a very weird way of defining
what
what it means to be a a tech worker
anyway but I mean the interesting thing
on the kind of free speech side of it
was fascinating to me because it was so
much like I should be able to say what I
think and yes that's true in a kind of
public forum but this is actually within
the company and the company basically
saying like well yes you have free
speech but we can also decide to fire
you like that doesn't preclude you from
you know you don't fit in our culture
anymore
which i think is fascinating that we
have reached a point that google can say
that that's not what their culture is or
what they don't what they don't want
their culture to be like received as
anyway yeah sure right but yeah it's
still indicative of this you know
engineering mentality of just like very
transactional like very data-driven
assumption or you know backing of of an
idea and saying like this is the way the
world works and all of these kind of
more just interventions are not valuable
in his mind I think that there is also
as far as biases within tech culture
within tech products go there is a very
valid argument that as technology
increases as we become more reliant on
automation on algorithms the biases that
once you might once be able to hold
somebody responsible for say hiring only
men or hiring whoever that that if an
algorithm is doing it now you're losing
that person to hold somebody accountable
to can you would you guys mind talking a
little bit about the role that explain
ability and transparency might might
play with some of these issues sure yeah
I mean I think there's this great
interest in like okay well we'll let the
like HR algorithm system do the work and
like then we have to say that it's not
biased because well and it's not a human
deciding so haha but then of course you
know what are you optimizing for this
gets back to my main question which is
okay success if you're if you're
building this algorithm to say like what
a successful person at Google looks like
then
you're already baking in a lot of
assumptions about their background their
history their schooling all of these
things that continue systemic you know
in justices in the sense that you know
you don't have access or you don't have
the right background or you are just not
a white man who gets along in his you
know coding cohort so I I I mean I think
there are a lot of people talking about
this especially in the kind of AI ethics
and shout out to Berkman Kline Center
and MIT for some of their work on this
on kind of accountability of algorithms
and saying you know these are yes they
are objective and yes they are
outsourcing the decision-making process
but looking into what the terms are
really does matter and I think that's
still a hard conversation yeah I mean I
was like there was a footnote in a book
that sherry Turkle wrote that was good I
kind of went back a lot and looked at AI
the one of the main and one of the
chapters is about a guy named John
McCarthy who was a professor at MIT and
then he moved to Stanford and he's the
one who came up with the term AI he was
an early computer science you know
pioneer but also AI pioneer and so the
whole obviously in the whole quest to
create a thinking being
again the idea thing of people's
machines machines as people thinking
that a brain itself is an entity that
could exist outside of a body just like
a lot of it really was a to me very odd
and revealing quest that these early
computer science pioneers had and so
sherry Turkle had so woodenly a key
scene in the book is between the debate
between John McCarthy and this professor
a my team Joseph Weizenbaum
over whether a computer could be a judge
and they're like they're really very
Hank you know they're very argued a lot
all the time they were I'm almost maybe
they appeared in debates a lot against
each other and McCarthy was like of
course a computer could be a judge a
computer can do anything as long as it's
programmed correctly it has all the
information it needs why couldn't do
anything and so why some bama was a
refugee from Nazi Germany that was a
really obscene that was where you is
obscene idea that you seek something as
human kneeling in the loss of humanity
it is humane as being a judge
a therapist and thinking that that could
be performed by a computer was just a
real disconnect with reality so and
sherry Turkle had this footnote on that
exact topic I think she knew what those
wise new eyes mouth before he died and
it was about how he she interviewed
minority students at MIT like in the
early 80s and they were very encouraging
of the idea of a judge being a program
of a computerized judge because they
thought you know we know judges are
biased and horrible and his computer
will be fair and I think was like the
era when they really believed you know
computers could actually be these
separate entities and there would be
this like thinking being and then you
know cut to ten years later and then you
know the review entirely switch because
I realized that basically it's being
given this garbage information about how
judges rule in reality what's it going
to learn how would it be different than
any better than what it's learning from
the kind of machine learning arguments
so all long way of saying that like the
these these computers are neither good
or bad obviously the people use them
that's the problem what their
information they're given they're not
going to any better than our society out
why would they be again is this fiction
that the computer or world is separate
from the real world it's like it's a
product of the world and if we have a
racist sexist society it's not going to
fix that problem how could it and I
think of one quote that wise a mountain
said which was that which was kind of a
carried over in the whole book was the
idea that a lot of the problems that
these people the computer programmers I
think that they're so great at math and
they should be solving all those other
problems he's like math is easy at least
for him it was but like actually solving
injustice or writing a poem like that's
hard so that it's that fundamental it's
connective thinking that if you're good
at programming or math that you actually
should run our society when we know how
hard it is to fix our society is the
fundamental problem I'd say do you feel
that that technology has any role to
play in terms of correcting correcting
these issues then I you know to convict
myself I think there was this famous
well there was this famous court case in
the eighties which was arguing that that
the death penalty should be ruled
you know invalid because they showed
systemic bias so I'd say I think data
and showing systemic bias can be very
enlightening to the public so I think
you you know and the
and I'm not using that and and didn't
basically said you have to prove that
there was racism in each case you can't
have some systemic argument that our
criminal justice system is unfair I've
proven it with with data so we should
fix it so I mean I on the other hand I
do think data could really enlighten us
about how how unjust our society is and
what we should work on fixing but I
don't think you know a program is going
to do that is that make sense I mean
yeah I mean this leads into kind of a
bigger question I had following up on
the book which is you know I think you
do an amazing job of kind of
articulating the ideology in the history
of where these concepts are coming from
and the kind of hacker mentality butting
up against the entrepreneurial model but
what I was left wanting more of was like
okay so so what and also what do we do
and I think one of the so I kind of
always go back to Lawrence Lessig's four
points of what we do to change things
this he wrote this in code and code to
data a long time ago and so one of those
things is okay we can we can decide what
the technology is optimizing for we can
decide you know what terms were either
designing the algorithms for or kind of
what direction we're leading for and
that still goes back to the question of
you know is it optimization towards
efficiency or optimization towards
justice right but I think there's still
other parts that we could start to
unpack like okay if the libertarian
approach is a problem or the mentality
that like this has led to huge monopoly
systems right we can start talking about
you know markets seems to be one of the
so Lawrence Lessig's model has markets
code law and norms are the four kind of
ways that one could or the levers that
one could change society or change where
things are going
I'm like hesitant to say that market
seems to not be a real possibility here
like we have
ended up in a monopoly situation network
effects basically mean that the market
leaver is kind of impossible right like
do we have an alternative to Facebook do
we have an alternative to Google do we
have an alternative to Amazon right kind
of yes but not really at the scale that
these companies are operating at which
is why we kind of get back to the
regulation problem that's the law piece
I'm scared because that's certainly not
going to be a functional lever for the
next four years
at least you know even looking to the
net neutrality moment where you know
we're sending all neutrality limitations
antitrust is still not really set to
address the way that these tech
companies are set up it doesn't really
apply to free services either right like
the standard ways that we look at
antitrust which are like competition
pricing harm to the consumer right these
kind of don't work and so I I think we
have to think about other ways to hold
these companies accountable but that has
to evolve into some new model that's not
you know based on our old our old
Weaver's well norms I think are
something right here we were certainly
seeing you know if we're seeing what
happened with sexual harassment and the
public that's a norms kind of kicking in
in a way and I and I guess I am leery of
the idea of code ever being useful
because again it's like not knowing what
you don't know so I mean like a
well-intentioned male a program or a you
may not think of administration you know
calendar it's like a and it isn't even
it's just like not yeah it's not it
won't be a viable solution so I do have
to you know so you say and certainly
it's you mentioned in your report too
that like the idea of what do we do now
is always a big you know big question
and and you know I think they're
characters in your paper who talked
about how hey I'm I'm putting out all
the problems give me credit for that I
don't have you know the solutions that's
you know not my department as
as they say and so but I do I did try
and the arguments are making were that
smaller local things if the points are
kind of making that are that need to be
fixed I was thinking though that like
the power of narrative that maybe I'm
mistaken I may in the book and maybe now
I try to talk about more is is to sort
of embrace this sort of individualism
argument and the because I do believe in
individual is and and and and and and
people you know self actualizing getting
the most out of their lives and maybe
the way to think of it is the way the
data is that people should have a right
to their data and that that is like a
way of framing it that that something is
like gone off the rails that it was just
considered normal for these companies
collect everything about you and even
though they're giving you the services
in exchange it's not really done in a
very transparent way and it's just
fundamentally wrong I I mean all I can
fall back are these like analogies that
like imagine we walk into a store and
someone follows you and go oh oh did you
buy that that's interesting I'll go tell
I'll make it da say about you and like I
mean it would be like unthinkable why it
would be a norm I know it mean like
people point out that like that um you
know may be an efficient thing is to go
to a store and you see that take a penny
add a penny and go take fifty five cents
and go what can i buy with this I mean
that is a I break a rule I don't know
but it's not our norm it's not how we
behave so I think partly maybe I am
hoping for a norm norm away from these
these beliefs and and a belief that we
as a society if it's still possible to
come together and make better rules so I
that's all I can fall back on and have
certain values like your data is yours
and and and partly I think liberal
libertarianism is one of the day because
even the way you frame it was snowed and
you know I in my gut I feel like if if
Google and Facebook and other companies
hadn't collected so much data to start
the government would never have dreamed
of it it's like they they were the cuz
they are the custodians of all this
material and they abused that and that's
like set us on a very wrong path and we
have to get back from that path I just
wasn't there someone the CIA director if
someone was saying out Facebook has a
better dossiers on people than we ever
could do because they because it
wouldn't work a government like coming
there and saying tell us everything you
bought and what you like it just
wouldn't you know it would be we were
raised a raise your antenna so I think
we we need to try to get
back or control or society I had said
pretty open-ended comment but even even
if that's and I totally agree with not
as a direction
I still wonder like how does that
actualize like does that mean we stopped
using Facebook does that mean we don't
let Facebook do certain things does that
mean we demand certain features and and
protections of these companies does that
mean we have a cup like collective
action movement about like you know [ __ ]
the default or some some kind of way of
getting into the the way to change it
right like yeah it's one thing to say
yes I need to have access to my data or
have ownership of my experience or you
know be able to voice my interests and
needs to determine the way that my news
feed is filtered right like we don't
even get to do make a Facebook group
about this right now
[Laughter]
yeah I do think it takes a movement I do
think you're pointing out like things
like Snowden I think the election are
gonna be galvanizing moments and I was
struck watching this hearing that I
watched to comment about about the
Senate Judiciary hearing that there was
a it was the the sharpest questioner was
this senator Republican from Louisiana
John Kennedy you asked just pointed the
best most pointed questions about what's
going on like does it could Facebook you
know give me a list if I'm gonna
advertise where people are depressed and
could I sell them alcohol could I you
know do you know who's overweight I mean
I sell them diet pills or you he and I
it's like it should transcend you know
petty partisan politics I don't think it
should transcend like you know greed
versus not greed or but I think that you
know middle America is definitely one
that's being hit hardest by all this is
their their their wealth is being taken
and being sent to the coasts you know by
and large so I think there is a chance
for a genuine movement I mean if there
is this you know belief in our political
system that there I do think that
something could change I think things
are galvanizing I'm hopeful I mean well
even in that case I think that's one of
those okay so if we're gonna define what
our norms are we at least have to have
all these examples and all these
pieces of saying like yes this is a
possible way that this advertising
platform could be used and oh by the way
we don't believe that that's an
appropriate use right I think it has
taken us a long long time to get enough
of those examples and enough of those
understandings of how those systems work
and what they're capable of and how
advertisers are using them for example
to even begin to establish a threshold
of what we are defining as appropriate
or not appropriate and for the most part
all of that is kind of hidden yeah but
it's heartening that like the senator I
hadn't thought of it I didn't articulate
nearly as well as that like he went
right at him and it was they were just
kind of having Hong as they were they
really very concrete it was very it was
great I it was really impressive so I
you know I mean there is a sense that
yeah then maybe that is some more of a
burden and maybe that's what you're
saying that the book or the next thing I
have to do is to really be more concrete
and more galvanizing that way I want to
just tell the history so it was really
like what Chris was saying was like I
wanted to just sort of say how did we
get here because I was genuinely like
baffled and I kind of came at this stuff
with a lot of optimism and Wikipedia is
like a real obsession of mine like I
wrote many many articles about it for
the ARBs that really saw that as like an
incredible like anarchic you know some
of these little parts become this
incredible thing and I sorry I do a lot
of optimism about it I'm more was just
trying to answer that question how did
we get here more than like how can we
get it back but that is definitely the
next like question I think we're gonna
have to open this up for questions in
just a minute I'm gonna ask one last
question and then if anybody in the
audience would like to ask questions
please go to one of these two
microphones here we would love to hear
from you because we are at MIT I am
obligated to ask you know what what role
does the university have for students
who are here who are designing things
who are making their own startups you
know what ethical considerations should
they be thinking of before moving into
the real world
Wow I mean because we're kind of saying
how the deck is so stack you know and
not they want to say to young people I
guess I mean there is a when I was super
advocates for local you know there's a
certain tender on garden and like try to
create I would think there must be a
real thrill and like trying to create a
small project that can have better
values maybe not be driven by the market
and and seeing that kind of fruition and
I do think there's got to be a way to
you know not to sort of you they were
they're basically saying now because of
the monopoly we're live system we're
living with now that even new companies
are just only looking to be acquired and
so I would say that that you know I mean
Who am I to sit there and say don't like
seek your billions but are your millions
but like that would be the message to
try to nurse or something that that is
smaller I think there is like a real
yearning for it I mean they're billions
which is weird that it that's accurate
here strikes me as very strange what
should I be thinking of before on when
they're on that path like what questions
do you feel that MIT students should be
asking when they're building their
groundbreaking technologies I mean I
think the hardest question to always
answer is you know you have one
intention for this technology whatever
it is that you're building how to
recognize the myriad ways that the same
technology could be used that's always a
really hard question to answer until
somebody has discovered some other way
to use it or to monetize it or to apply
it to you know weapons and military
industrial complex right so I think
that's probably like learning how to see
your own effort from multiple angles
I can target your own idea yeah yeah by
so many different people right like
that's the thing I think that's missing
from a lot of what happens in Silicon
Valley is like how much user testing do
they really do where a user gets to tell
them how they feel they do so much a be
testing but does that ever tell you what
my intention was as a user my experience
my emotions all of these things where
are you basing right now there's
in the market as their as the only way
to sort of see what the intent you know
and the throw something out in this
pivoting right they call it like a pivot
yeah there's so many assumptions in the
way that most of these technologies are
operating that and that's kind of by
design right like the data-driven
approach is that we can look at what the
behavioral data is and then determine
like what's gonna get you to spend more
time or what's gonna get you to spend
more money and that doesn't get into
anything about like what my actual
intentions are so yeah try talk to
actually talk to people yeah yeah I
would say forging real connections
instead of virtual ones would be a real
way to interrogate your idea because I
think even even you know Mark Zuckerberg
scum around the idea that there's more
to there has to be some real basis to
these relationships otherwise it doesn't
which is I I think so much of what we're
talking about is like the leadership
role that you know these individual
especially in the way that you've
structured the book is like the men who
are in charge who you know have these
ideologies but you know that filters
into the culture of these companies and
it's actually I think it's really
imperative to think about the more
systemic contextual way that this these
ideas get played out and you know how
old that is baked into what you're
you're you know engineering goals are
your your efficiency or like how how is
your job
you know checked right like what's your
performance review having some control
over those questions seems to be another
way that we could like cut into you know
the the overall culture all right we are
gonna open this up to audience questions
now if you would like to ask please use
one of these microphones please be kind
and we're gonna switch off from one to
the other
we'll start at this one over here and
then next one is coming over to you
my name is Nina Linton I'm here from the
humanist chaplaincy at Harvard and the
humanist table in Harvard Square so
thank you so much to radio
and the folks for bringing this
important topic out in the open I wanted
to ask the question about the Sarah you
had mentioned that the the technologies
don't take people's feelings into
account and I wanted to say from an
ethical perspective as I experienced
that I believe the use of the the
emotions you know like an anger that is
a proxy for hooking into the dopamine
circuits and creating an addictive
experience which excuse me if my voice
is breaking I think is very unethical
and I wonder what your feelings would be
about how to answ how to bring these you
know bring this to awareness absolutely
this you know this is like whiskey and
cigarettes and rest of it right yeah how
do we regulate those kinds of things
that's a great question um there's a
couple things one is you know there are
already engineers and designers who are
recognizing that I mean that's that's
again gets back to the optimization
question are you is it really just to
get you to keep thrall scrolling through
and Auto refreshing and you know
infinite feed right Tristan Harris is
one of these engineers and designers
former Google person who is working on
the question of time well-spent
so time well-spent iö and that's really
driven by this kind of okay we're
engineers and designers like we can
design these systems in better ways on
the addiction side of things I really
love I think she used to be at MIT now
she's at NYU but Natasha dau Jules work
she has a book called addiction by
design and it's it's actually about slot
machines but is of course very relevant
to the design of any technological
interface and yeah she's very clearly
articulating this as like these systems
are designed to keep you in flow keep
you going
not necessarily to keep you winning and
that's kind of a really interesting look
at specifically such a clear use of
addiction but people are have you know
naturally taken that and applied it to
these more kind of
broad consumer interfaces hello my name
is le Doan I was born raised in Bay Area
Silicon Valley come from all this stuff
and yeah there's a lot of complexity
there there's plenty of good things
there's plenty of bad things I think one
thing that really struck me was your
argument about inefficiency of if you
have some large corporation efficiently
optimizing to take over some market or
some product whatever it is and you're
squeezing out maybe the small people who
live on the crumbs
I see also like a flipside I can argue
you know when you pay a medical bill
who's still advocating for an efficiency
when we have trillions of dollars of
waste in the healthcare industry and it
goes both ways there's like a huge cost
to inefficiency and there's also a huge
cost of the people that you squeeze out
there and so I'm trying to think if if
you had a tech company go through and
try to you know completely redo
healthcare and make it a very efficient
system you might be able to save
trillions of dollars but what happened
all the people who you got squeezed out
from that system and I think it's you
can't really paint it in black and white
either way there's just there's just
trade-offs yeah I would think in having
universal health care is is a much more
important goal than either one of those
things yeah so in my opinion so I mean I
totally hear you and of course it's like
there's a reason why these companies are
successful and they're popular because
if there there was a need for efficiency
and to for hailing cars or for shopping
and so I guess we're just sort of saying
it needs to have a higher goal I think
boys Sarah is like framing is really
what is really good that like you know
the idea of if your goal is just a
maximize profit that is not a good goal
so that could explain why you'd want
people be addicted because it maximizes
your profit but it's not good for
society maybe another way of thinking
besides the Gleaner now is used to think
of it it's just like a pollution the way
the first question is that these are you
know she's been taking actual alcohol
companies tobacco companies they also
are giving people what they want they're
very popular I mean it's like that's
something the way you judge these things
so III think we need to have of course
the enthusiasm and the creativity is
really vital to our society but it isn't
have some kind of larger goal where
we're gonna have a problem and we are
having a problem just the idea that you
know why hasn't Silicon Valley
completely disrupted the healthcare
industry yet and I think it really comes
down to the allergy to
highly regulated ecosystem right like
that is so far down the road of like we
just aren't going to touch that I mean
looking at the quantified self community
and and quantified self devices you know
none of those are medical devices for a
reason yeah trackers you know fitbit's
you know a lot of these companies like
wanted to start getting into the what's
the try coder like let me scan your face
and see if you have like Star Trek
vision you know for like how sick you
are and you know to have a checkup
that's just like like checkup in five
seconds right the reason that that
company is kind of you probably haven't
heard of it is that you know they've
gotten so far back with FDA approvals
and things like what do you think of the
life hacking stuff in this sort of like
the blood transfusions and the you know
because that's also part of that culture
to me again I was you talk about you
writing you think on a meta level I was
trying to think about like the idea of
to me it was related to the idea of
creating artificial intelligence and the
idea of kind of giving birth to yourself
that not ever dying and sort of being
again detached from reality and thinking
of your brain is something could be on
the cloud that lives forever so that's
how isin viewed in that kind of in that
kind of context of the the ideologies of
that led to computer science how do you
see that the bio hacking yeah that kind
of happened is that medical or or is
that I mean certainly but then you know
you've got a lot of hacker types who are
you know willing to experiment on their
bodies and just think there's something
about thinking differently about your
like corporeal place in the world and
you know whether or not that's a sacred
thing or not you know but that's getting
I'm getting him deep in the weeds but
thank you so much thank you for the
engaging discussion my name is Marty I'm
a graduate student in mechanical
engineering so I grew up in India and
the one thing that really struck me when
once I moved here was the commitment to
free speech and the
action of First Amendment that the
Supreme Court has provided in this
country which is unparalleled in my
opinion so I was really taken aback when
you mentioned free speech as a
libertarian value which i think is as
much a liberal or conservative value and
I wonder what you mean by abuse of free
speech of course Internet is not the
best place for for cordial discussions
and we all know that but how do you
think we can really maintain the spirit
of the First Amendment I'm going ahead
write something people argue about I
mean you could argue limiting the amount
of people can donate to campaigns is a
restriction on free speech and we
currently live in a Supreme Court that
thinks that any rich person be able to
give as much money as possible to effect
election and that's that is their
freedom corporations people are people
as well and and and so I mean that
either could be very enlightening I see
well I actually thought the the Russian
meddling in our election was really
revealing it's because it really put the
lie to that argument of ultimate free
speech because if you really believe
free speech is just absolute and it's
just all these Russian outlets or any
other meddlers we're doing we're putting
words and pictures together what's the
problem
what's the problem and antagonizing
people are getting people to hate each
other it's just words and pictures but
obviously they are there there's a sort
of a there's a consensus I think in our
country that that was a bad thing maybe
our president doesn't agree but almost
everyone else agrees that that was a bad
thing to have a foreign country try to
stir bintang as among oral our people
and try to pick a winner of our election
so that we eliminate on free speech at
one level but to me that seems a very
necessary one so I totally hear you I
want people to express themselves and
you know that's hard to belittle that
and I understand that if you live in a
society where you can't do that how
harmful that is but there are real costs
too you know and and in essence like
places like Twitter are allowing
incredible it isn't random anger it's
anger directed certain groups it's like
you have to sort of get and look at it
in actual historical context I mean
that's how I would argue and that it's
almost like thinking of as code to think
of that that this thing called the
ultimate free speech is just gonna work
is it's the right thing to do and not
right
all the actual real real facts and
that's my view of it I mean yeah I mean
I would add especially in the Twitter
context I think they've done so much to
protect free speech that they do that it
hampers them from addressing very
serious things and behaviors like
harassment and you know how to embed
checks on that kind of behavior in the
system I think they've done a whole lot
and tried to do a whole lot so far but I
think there are a lot of people who are
really underwhelmed by how that gets
manifest in the code and how you know as
a user who's being harassed like what
are your what can you do aside from just
blocking all these you know the
apartment exam is the scaling idea that
it should be automated instead of it you
know if you were living in a normal
society if you were someone really
picking on someone in a harsh way we
would serve say don't do that and I
would say you say it's my freedom to
yell at this one person make them feel
real uncomfortable so they run away but
we would say no don't do that I think
you know I mean that's like if that's
the fundamental and when you sort of
abstract it to this level
it's my speech rights it becomes you
know I think dangerous I mean that's but
I totally hear your point I mean I guess
we disagree hi student at MIT I'm also a
6-year moderator on reddit so nice
piggybacking off of that question where
do you feel you know you talked a lot
about governance and in your reply to
the last question you know you mentioned
that these companies believe that all of
these regulatory behavior should be
algorithmically controlled or
administered but the fact is that they
still rely quite heavily on human
moderation whether it's commercial or
volunteer like such as in my case so
what do you see as the current place and
possibly future potential of human
moderation be a commercial or volunteer
within these online social spaces back
to Wikipedia which does a lot of I think
they do some automated policing but they
do a lot of human volunteers and I think
it fundamentally it has to be human I
think that's the sort of when we talk
about what's bad about big it's not just
the monopoly part it's that it is not
human it's not you
scale and I remember there's a book
called the boy kings it
yeah and so if she said a beautiful
description about how like the
scaleability was this the most important
things is growing fast and scalability
really meant you couldn't be human human
customer service and was just removing
people out of it and that's just
fundamentally Wikipedia's managed to
grow quite big but not billions by using
people who are very motivated to do the
right thing so I yeah I think it's kind
of vital you have to have a human
community that it will respond I mean I
think it's like vital yeah I think it
gets back to the norms question as well
as to you know who's determining how
norms are expressed for algorithms or
for you know automated platforms right
that's a pretty hard question so yeah
that's where the the interplay between
technology and humans or you know the
filter through the algorithm but then
have a human look at it and I I kind of
stand on the side of you know I think
we're gonna be working alongside of
technologies and a eyes and whatever
else for a long time and it's not just
gonna be it either or it's gonna be both
um so my name is eNOS I'm a postdoc at
MIT and a social scientist by training
and I guess I look at this conversation
and your book actually from the
perspective of both a political
scientist and your peon I guess right
and we do have a slightly different
standards and in a way I cannot help but
sort of want to ask you where do you see
the political system you know in all of
this because ultimately I would argue
that you know what we see in terms of
because you take sort of an in very
individualistic sort of approach
explanatory approaches which is valid
and very interesting but I would argue
that ultimately this is about you know
how much influence do we want to give
government and how much influence do we
want to have on our own and that's why
we have you know like the German the
German Court case or why we have the
European Commission you know being very
explicit about the use of cookies right
now so if you could elaborate a little
bit on
yeah I do think in the book I definitely
hold up Europe as a model that way I
again it's the idea of the individual
like it's hard to know what your you're
describing as individuality because the
government is protecting individuals I
think in America would be like how dare
the government be involved in protecting
me you know I mean so that's the kind of
catch-22 here in America it me frame it
that way look how it isn't great we got
all these rules so he protect
individuals we were like get the
government off my back you know get the
government off my Medicaid I mean it's
like they don't really appreciate what
is being done in that rehab so I do
think that's exactly I think of you know
the right to be forgotten is another you
know we talk about free speech that's
another case where you know in Europe
they have this rule that basically says
you have the right to we've been kind of
you've served you're done something
wrong you've served your time you've a
right to serve not have it be talked
about you that way that you that you
know you did something 20 years ago it
should be the first thing you see on
Google and but again Wikipedia I
remember discussing this with the
executive director Wikipedia they very
much don't like that there are
encyclopedia they if you committed a you
know a bank when I say bank robber even
something almost as many more when
declared bankruptcy 20 years ago that's
a fact it's part of your biography it
should be in there how dare you say we
can't put that in but I do think that's
another reasonable regulation on
recognizing how the Internet is
different than a newspaper or court
record like in the old days we're these
things were very there were no limits
and things were published but it was
very hard to go to the court to find out
what happened who declared bankruptcy if
you want that effort okay you can find
out 20 years glad to clear bankruptcy
but now it's immediately the first thing
it's said about you you have to sort of
bend you know you have to adapt for that
and that that's a different definition
of free speech I think so yeah I would
take it one step further which is I
think part of what you're getting at is
like what's at stake here is the
legitimacy of these companies and and
individuals to govern and rule us right
like they're as institutions we've kind
of opted in to living in their worlds
and those are very different worlds from
like the traditional transnational like
West feeling and view of the world right
and that's particularly interesting
especially when we're talking about like
Zuckerberg aspiration
specifically to you know understand that
he has built like the largest or coming
beginning to be the largest community
right so I feel like that kind of
political term legitimacy is really
operative here to say like did we sign
up for this actually are these the
leaders are these the ideas that we
believe in and if not what do we do
about that
and my last point here is that my my
hope exists on the EU and the GDP are
and so yeah GDP or GDP are is the
general data protection regulation which
is coming out or applies in I think May
2018 this is data protection and but the
big thing here is that any company that
serves EU citizens could potentially
serve somebody visiting or a tu citizen
visiting the United States so like it
applies blanket to basically any company
especially all these ones were talking
about if they operate and serve you
citizens that is like the best hope for
any solid regulation and I think it's a
kind of least common denominator
situation where you know in the same way
that cars are manufactured to meet the
highest standards California I think
we're going to see that kind of level of
regulation obviously it's a little
easier to change user experience based
on geography so that's kind of a
trickier loophole element of this but I
am hopeful that that's at least pushing
the conversation in the right direction
you're looking to Germany is the world
leader in the yeah I
everything.you I had so many thoughts
while you are talking cuz this is my
life and all the articles you brought up
and all the people you named or give us
all your engineering product manager
to work in the Bay Area and is now at
Berkman with Sarah focusing on the
social responsibilities of my field
which is tech and engineering and also
the intersection of tech and government
and how do we get policy people to
understand technology but also how do we
get technologists even a sliver of
interest in what's going on over in DC
not only to make a government better but
also to impact policies in ways that
maybe folks in the Silicon Valley can
also respect and and care about but what
I wrote down notes cuz I know I would
just start rambling and lose my train of
thought I had on the first point of
harassment diversity in tech there are a
lot of women who've spoken out they
don't get the same kind of coverage as
maybe the people in the media but Kelly
Ellis Allen pal Erica Baker Susan Fowler
and all the people who spoke out against
Justin Cal back when he was a VC and so
many other countless really really brave
women I don't know how to really amplify
them even more and get the same kind of
coverage that you see from for them to
have maybe women journalists I mean we
were talking on women journal it's not
women brave women in the field were
throwing that you know and a lot of the
stories about media been women
journalists writing about so yeah and
then in addition to that something you
said no that really stood out to me in
this era also talked about was this idea
of both not only the market driving
decisions but also this idea of like
utopia you know you're gonna connect all
these people and the world's gonna be a
beautiful place of rainbows and unicorns
and that's what and the second part for
me because coming here to this area this
is my first time in Cambridge I've been
here three months I often hear the
narrative if those people will just stop
caring about money maybe they'll care
about users but on the ground a lot of
the engineers and the some of you
engineering students in this room
probably have this deep like sense of
we're here because we're changing the
world
they Facebook's mission of like
connecting people and Google's do cool
things that matter is that drives a lot
of these engineers to go there if you
talk to many of the engineers you're
like what's the average rep or the site
and your revenue for your company though
I don't know they even put like their
ads and marketing people and they over
to different campus and
engineers here's like an unlimited pot
of money to go do whatever you want and
so in the world are people actually are
only driven by money maybe we can help
figure out what to do there but what do
we do when people generally believe that
what they're doing is so good and that
we're at Google because we're gonna make
the world a safer place because this is
where real security happens or work
aware at Google because there's the
power money here to really connect the
world and teach someone in developing
regions how to farm so they can pull
themselves out of pot like these deep
missions but then not think about and
that for me is a much harder thing to
put a finger on you you can even take
your anecdote and switch it around and
say there's something wrong about
demeaning the marketing and advertising
people it's like they're part of your
company so the idea of like saying these
are you know the because it really
you're saying that they're they're not
they're not of a pure mission like
engineers but it's also they're not as
smart as we are and so they should be
over there and that's another part of it
is that is that seduction that they I
was very I wonder you think of this but
I was very struck with the argument of
this that the computer is a closed world
I don't use a programmer so that you you
you are in such control there and you
can make the rules and it's so clean and
it all makes sense to your mind and that
that's kind of you know I I maybe it's
like unfair but I like to talk about how
Zuckerberg his first program was was a
risk game based on Julius Caesar and you
know it's like he's doing world conquest
now in real life and it's like who cares
what he's doing on the computer that's
that's fine but like it's it's that it's
that crossing off the screen to reality
that is what the books really about and
I owner it were you drawn to come
programming because of that like closed
world where it all kind of made sense
and is that what we're sort of talking
about when I talk about rainbows and
unicorns that like they can create a
world that is you know coherent that way
yeah I it's it's so interesting to hear
you say that that wasn't what drew me to
the field I think perhaps there are
groups that think of it that way as well
I was drawn in by like the Utopia of
well I really can help the whole world
connect with each other and do all these
things and candidly studying computer
science
this was back to what Sarah was saying
what is it let your graded on in class
it's your algorithms your how create
your right like something with theory
classes
what is it that people's performance
reviews are at these companies they
don't touch on ethics our users like all
that is separate so that wasn't what was
drew me in but I definitely think the
way we're trained and the way what the
way we're what's the right word the way
we're graded or our performance reviews
that companies definitely gears towards
developing a certain way even if we have
certain interests in mine I don't know
how to fix that it's what I'm thinking
about all the time and the actual impact
right like if that's what you believe
you're doing how do you know that you're
doing it yeah like how do you check that
you're doing that and I don't think most
companies have a way of following
through on that and there's not room for
that right like once you finish one
product or feature or whatever you're on
to the next thing and like how much
aside from using it yourself do you
really get to understand how it's
impacting users how users actually use
it what their experiences are and you
both brought this up like how do we get
people to think very critically about
the impact of what we were gun fires
different training rates social science
other skills that are not what these
people have and it's the arrogance of
thinking that I'm good at programming
I'm also good at analyzing how my my
work will affect the city it's like why
why would you be good at that I mean it
doesn't you know one final and I'll sit
down I promise there's you I would love
even talk to you more known when I was
some point later about your experience
covering this field for so long there
are definitely these roles are seen as
idols in the tech field mostly men but
people who people look to as like people
who paved the way and they're usually in
like the Hard quote real computer
science fields oh so the leaders in AI
or some of the leaders who wrote who the
original writers of the the main
algorithm for Google search who weren't
there and when they say stuff people
people really listen things they say
aren't usually around ethics or users
they talk about really efficient
algorithms and different things like
that so perhaps over there are ways we
can influence the the leaders that many
people listen to to really yeah I found
it I mean the interesting thing doing
the book I was like I would collect like
all the each saying how smart the old
one other one was but also like how
everyone was insecure about their own
intelligence so you go to kora and
there's like is marcus zuckerberg a
great programmer and it's like of course
he has anyone could have done that you
know blah blah john mccarthy who was
like the sensual figure in this book you
know was a mathematics professor at
stanford assistant professor passed over
for tenure went to Dartmouth and then
MIT became a computer scientist was
brought back to Stanford as a full
professor and mathematicians were like
oh the computer science I was a very
easy guy couldn't hack as a
mathematician suddenly he's like a full
professor so I mean there's always no
one is secure when you have this world
of constantly everyone's got to be the
smartest and so I but you know I hear
you it's like maybe an idol would be the
way to get some changed you know I have
some important person like endorses
stuff yeah for your panel and insightful
conversation my name is Stefani I'm a
graduate student in personal robots
group and I had a quick question around
what you mentioned from Lawrence Lessig
Sarah so I really think like a lot of
these issues and externalities of scale
came to be because of lack of good
business models so one question and Eric
von Hippel here at MIT actually just
released a new book about free
innovation first he had democratizing
innovation and then it's like free
innovation so it's like how do we think
of monetizing value when you're not you
know aiming for acquiring but actually
like how do we create and value what we
we create and do you really think it's
gonna become like decentralized
blockchain everyone owns the data or
we're gonna go back to our tribes that
are interconnected like what are the
scenarios you're imagining because I'm
European as well and it was very
interesting I was just like a summit of
entrepreneurship in Estonia last week
and there was like such a big debate
around scale ups like the startups that
need to scale and people were really
revolting against that like young people
senior people everyone was like really
do we need to scale like is that always
the model of success so yeah there was a
lot in there but I'm curious what you
think it's great questions so I think
that again gets to the optimization
quest
like it's scale the optimization
question I think you know in the in your
account of Facebook it's purely about
like well we don't know what the the
business model is like they didn't know
what the business model it was for a
very very long time but the question was
scale and like a network effects right
so we'll figure out yeah right yeah and
by the way like we'll bring in Sheryl
Sandberg but that's another story so
yeah I mean I think it's really hard for
people to like imagine other formats
aside from like okay well you know maybe
Mastodon or maybe what's the other one
diaspora like where how long have we
talked about that since you know it
first came out and we talked about it as
like one possible way to disrupt
Facebook sure diaspora
I think was you know a distributed
locally hosted social network
infrastructure to not have any
centralized kind of control over
information and data also I think some
of the guys were former Facebook guys is
that Ray or NYU I don't know I forget um
and then Mastodon similarly I think but
more for like a Twitter model maybe
that's a rough a rough description yeah
I mean the thing with even thinking
about different models like blockchain
black teen in itself like ideologically
is a very libertarian yeah I mean wish
even she's phrasing it as enchanted and
thought about that like even the idea of
you know tribes oh that you know I mean
they're probably making more sense to
say that their communities you belong to
or maybe they're it's okay to share but
it's it isn't this universality of like
I'm an individual and the world and
we're connecting like that I would say
the other thing about business models is
that you know again that's to fall back
on regulation but the idea is that
you're supposed to make a penalty for
things that are harmful and that's why
you don't pollute otherwise it would be
a great business models like chop all
the trees down and pollute the river and
you know you make the most money so I
think it is on us to sort of
add the costs to this so that that will
that's the house to work yeah to extract
the most value to rates again to extract
the most value from that from from that
or what they're doing with that's right
alternative right right as opposed to
the bathroom right yeah so I think it
might one other
Weaver is the like consumer demand side
of things right so even if we if it's
hard to imagine a world without Facebook
and Amazon and Google and Apple what
does it look like if we start demanding
different versions of those things we're
different features are different you
know ways of interacting with these
companies and I think that's really hard
for people to get their heads around but
you know is probably the only way these
companies are gonna change so I mean the
pessimistic view also is that these
companies are so big and powerful that
it's very hard they're gonna stop this
from happening and that that it when you
get set and I'm pessimistic if that's
what you think about the power they have
to lobby and and you know there's such
you know I mean I know a president has
found a pointing this out that doesn't
mean it's wrong that Jeff Bezos owns
Washington Post if it's it's it's a it
certainly led to some good things but
it's an ominous I think anyone watching
you ought to be it's an ominous thing
you know I think it's kind of undeniable
so the the fear that they're so
entrenched is definitely a problem thank
you
and I come from the sociological
perspective of having delivered mail for
30 years in San Mateo California right
smack in the middle of Silicon Valley so
you have seen the technology so I have
seen the houses go up hundreds of
thousands
I didn't Easy Rose took property and had
you know people that are 30 years old
and worked for Google and work for
Facebook and where for whatever come
into these neighborhoods and buy the
houses and the people get pushed out
from those houses are the people that
are now the contract workers that help
support Facebook and Google and these
are not not just the the advertising
people that use books but the people
that work in the cafeteria the people
that drive the dry cleaning cars that
bring the cleaning to these people so
they can work 15 20 hours a day and
they're not their employees even though
they spend full time there yet they have
to like spend more time on the internet
getting drawn in to say can you pick up
another shift yet you can't go over 40
hours because then we might have to pay
you benefits we might have to pay you so
the fact that there's a disconnect
between like the Zuckerberg foundation
the Chan Zuckerberg foundation right now
I read an article about how they're
trying to work on this homeless problem
well one of the people I know that is
actually homeless is somebody that lost
the benefits from a job and couldn't and
only has part-time so they only value
the core center there of who they are
but they don't have any value of the
people that truly support the company
all the outside workers I think maybe
ement MIT popping it does have adjunct
professors but I bet you the person
that's working in the boiler room is an
MIT employee and pabe gets full benefits
and the lack of benefits is destroying
the middle class they've so much wealth
that's what's very peculiar about it you
feel like they could at least take care
of their own I mean we're talking about
societal effects but this is their
immediate backyard it's really I think
the most common argument that they make
is like well our core business is not
the cafeteria and cleaning like that we
as these companies are going to do only
our core business
and like that's the exact of course okay
a stirrup company she was number eight
well I mean she had to travel to Paris
and stay in a room with five other guys
where she was sexually assaulted by one
of them but this was before the company
had a PR department or an HR department
sorry an HR department where you learned
what the rules were so it a lot of these
startups are very rogue and yet they
don't understand how it is to value
everyone but but even thing that the
logic of saying that it's not part of
our core business it's like well how you
having food I mean like well how are you
halls being clean and I in the book I
talk about the there's a philosopher
susan muller Oken who argued that
basically libertarianism is
anti-feminist by definition it's like
not a coincidence that it's all tech
pros because basically it come from
it's based on this fiction that like
that you could be a Google employee but
the food just shows up magically or so I
mean but libertarianism is kind of our
the argument you show up in life you're
an adult male you don't owe any debt to
anyone who raised you or the community
that raised to you you just it's like
then it all makes sense I would at least
agree that um libertarians would make
sense of you felt it was a fair playing
field if your ideologies that work is
what you should reward okay that might
make sense but we know it's not a fair
it's not a fair playing field by
definition it's a faulty but logic but
that it kind of predicate on devaluing
women and the role of family and women
in in getting us here to adulthood so
her after did she end up staying within
HR department and and that person did
get fired just by a conversation but she
was really worried about actually losing
her job and didn't right so that's a
good thing but probably because she was
really good at her job and it was like
he maybe wasn't as much but it shouldn't
have happened but there weren't the the
things set in place but this is one
thing I think could possibly be a way to
like bring everybody around is like if
all of the amaz
drivers that are hired right now for the
holidays if like December 23rd they all
went on to take a shift people would be
like oh my gosh are they counter of fact
there are hope in that sense it's true
thank you hi I'm max I'm a undergraduate
in mechanical engineering and part of
the person robotics group as an engineer
who's really interested in user centered
design and getting into that in
particular how design conversation had
to change for different users I've
noticed that a lot of the conversations
tend to be stuck in either academia or
these design firms and that's where a
lot of these conversations kind of exist
like even in my capstone class the a
huge emphasis they put on user
experience on user design is great but
then the shift between the jobs that
people end up taking and the frameworks
of the jobs end up taking is kind of
like very starch to me and I was
wondering like as somebody who's going
into engineering field and wanting to be
a professional in this or like people
all of us here as consumers like how do
we see that shift in thinking and these
larger companies that's a great question
I mean I think the best way to get in is
to like make that a business case right
like this is going to lead to better
experiences and better you know better
user like value right I think the
question is how to speak their language
and put a number on it or you know
integrate it into the the kind of way
that they want to value their their
process and there you know development I
don't know I mean that's a tough
question I think I think it's also just
a question of like we're finding those
people in the institutions themselves
and in the companies themselves who are
thinking like that and have been
influenced in those ways or just working
outside of it right like Tristan Harris
leaves Google to
kind of advocate on a large scale to
influence a bunch of designers to be
asking these questions in their you know
institutions from the bottom up right
I think that's arguably the most
effective way to kind of have the ethics
from the bottom up so high thank you
guys for the work you do to bring this
these very important issues to light my
name is Eden I am a resident fellow at
Harvard Divinity School so shout out to
the actually thank you for coming yeah I
worked on tech policy in the Obama
administration so I'm kind of a weird
hybrid person we need all of these
hybrid people that's like that is what
is missing yeah so that so my question
is sort of related to that I mean um
one thing that I think a lot about is
during the Obama administration we did a
lot of work to bring all these techies
into government in part because it's
like alright well
if you want things to change then come
join us right and so I'm thinking about
this norms question this how do we
interrogate our own products and if it's
even realistic to talk about having
teams that are within the you know
leadership of some of these companies
whose job it is precisely to do that to
think about what are the effects on
humanity what is the justice lens of
this stuff because there's an element of
if you're not if that's not your job to
do it there it's like a frog in boiling
water problem of like you just you
forget that how how to look at those
things right or you tell yourself it's
easy to kind of to believe the narrative
of we're here and we're changing the
world in these ways or those ways or
even if the product this sort of aspect
to the product that you're working on
maybe is connecting people to education
who wouldn't otherwise have it your job
is not to look at a macro level at how
the overall company is influencing the
direction of things and so should those
of us who are talking about these issues
it strikes me that a lot of us should
talk about joining the companies
themselves but I also wonder if that
sounds idealistic that like people could
actually be empowered in those roles
like what would it take from Mark
Zuckerberg to say yes we want a team
that does this
it would mean having the humility
to admit that like right now they're not
doing those things so that's I think
they're certainly thinking about it
right now
at least from a kind of oversight
perspective for a bunch of different
reasons but maybe not quite to villain
to the level like having a chief you
know human experience officer or
something you know some version of that
yeah I mean I think this is why it's
really important to not only look at the
individuals in charge and the Zuckerburg
but also to look at the systemic support
systems around them like what is the
institutional org chart for Facebook
right like that matters for Google that
matters and how does that change over
time
that also really matters as these
companies scale as they get bigger as
they start touching more things right
and I think that is an aside from like
trolling LinkedIn like how how do we as
a public get to look into that
maybe the shareholder like 10k has a
little bit of insight into that but
probably not much yeah everything some
response to agitation so I think the
book was you know didn't dwell on this
but a major absence is like lack of a
labor movement and that that that is
what their need to be these checks or I
haven't believe me in there could be I'm
sure long let me boy labor unions are
inefficient but they serve as a very
valuable when you see with the whole of
society you see that you could see labor
unions as being efficient inefficient
and and and giving bad incentives
whatever the criticism would be but the
service vital role to check these
companies and like they're not going to
do it voluntarily we're saying it's not
going to be self regulations not going
to be them appointing someone to serve
this role is only INRI and reaction to
the bad press and the valid concern
about the election that's leading to
some change if there's education about
lack of diversity that could lead to
some change if there were actual labor
union that could that would actually be
able to strike and really affect the
balance of power that's the only thing
that are gonna I think make them change
and it's not beyond the realm of
possibility that would happen that's but
that I think you expect an org chart or
somehow that with like that
won't happen voluntarily because I think
they think they are doing the best
that's why was if any message of the
book was that they think they were doing
the best job with user experience and
they will say look how successful they
are that is how I know I'm doing a great
job and you know you're talking about
ethics or whatever these things are like
go back to the example the Google
designer he was saying I have a vision
for Google I have a human my vision for
how it should look I'm a designer I
study this and they're like we're gonna
just test it then and people are gonna
like what we do and that's I mean it's
just like they're not speaking the same
language I would say it doesn't compute
I would say what we're talking about
that strikes me though that maybe now
we're at a moment when they can no
longer say we're a morally neutral
platform and so we don't need people
whose job it is to think about these
things but again that may be naive of me
it just seems like if there's a moment
to push on it this may be as I was just
add like you know there's all any
product goes through okay like the
lawyers have to do the checkbox right
like is this before you ship like the
lawyers are the last step right and
engineers hate this because it's like oh
we built all this stuff and like now the
lawyers are saying we can't do it or
like it's because it's not integrated
into the process that's I so imagine
that but like not just lawyers
integrated into the process but like who
are those people how do they get hired
this is like huge case for human with
our calculus scores you know I mean yeah
right
but huge case for the humanists to find
jobs in these companies it's not just
the engineers that we need so and last
question you've been waiting so
patiently thank you hi my name is
Heather and I'm a lawyer but not one of
the lawyers you were talking about and
the thing that has struck me is that
what we study in law school largely is
how the rules got there and why we have
them and the internet seems to be a
giant erasure of history and why we do
things because you know I know lots of
Engineers and
the general mindset of Engineers is we
can figure out anything and so that
means that expertise is not valued
because we can always learn it we have
all this information out here but
they've forgotten the part about bad
information is not helpful and so when
you have a platform that has no way for
you to tell what's good information and
what's bad information you make bad
decisions and you know the in my
corporations class the first thing we
studied was taxi cabs not be not
actually the uber issue really but more
that what they used to do to avoid
liability was one car one corporation
ten cents in the bank and so on that's
that's why we have the rule of piercing
the corporate veil if you don't
capitalize your corporation then guess
what you don't get the benefit and we're
losing all of this because we have all
of these people who are so much smarter
than everybody else that they've decided
they don't need it and and they're also
really young and they haven't lived and
they haven't seen that there were
reasons for why we do things a
particular way and yes we should Rhian
them periodically but we should
recognize that there is a reason yeah
there's this thing called the Chesterton
gate you notice a GK Justin talked about
the idea you walk in a field and you see
a gate there and you're just like well
it makes no sense in the middle of a
field you know obviously I'll just tear
it down and he's saying you should at
least have the ability to go someone put
it there there was probably some reason
like I don't know that it's the right
reason but like it things don't just ran
they have some respect for like you're
saying history and context and he came
out I think from a right-wing
perspective a very conservative
perspective criticizing George Bernard
Shaw and like you could see why it's a
fundamental what we're talking I was
pretty
servant of values and let in reality
these libertarians I'm talking about are
highly highly radical I mean you know in
a sense like you not let since we've
seen since like you know the the Russian
Revolution or something that the lack of
respect for institutions and for history
and and this belief that progress is
this mysterious things that happen
instantaneously so I think we I think we
the stakes are very high and sometimes
easy to get confused by what what's
being pushed forward but it's really a
scary dangerous ideology and that's what
I was trying to say in the book for sure
yeah yeah I think you know to address
the kind of allergy to regulations but
you know that's a perfect example right
like there's a reason the taxis are
regulated or you know have rules around
them this is the kind of uber model
right like well we're just gonna make it
more efficient like that's all we're
trying to do so regulations of taxis and
local jurisdictions don't matter right
like that was quite literally like the
words that came out of Travis Callen as
his mouth but we all know where he has
ended up but all of that is to say like
it's worth acknowledging that like
technology has politics and like there
are you know the the libertarian stance
is such that it's like I'm just a
political like this is this is efficient
this is you know markets driven there is
no politics involved and I think what we
can really push against is like yes
there are politics involved it's you
know to call it out and call it a spade
a spade
there's the line from the band Rush that
says you know if you choose not to the
side you still made a choice and as he
was saying they said well actually was
Pascal is that that but so maybe it's a
little more weighty that way but that's
the myth that they believe they're not
making decisions but in fact they're
making huge decisions additionally the
way you ask a question has an answer
embedded in it absolutely I mean that's
what you learn in legal writing
one last reminder before we give a big
round of applause to our speakers no
smoke is up here for sale I cannot
recommend it highly enough so please go
buy it and our mailing list if you are
interested in hearing about further
radiation storms is right over here
please join me in giving a really good
[Applause]